Mollie Kuramoto liable careful guys make
sure that you try these supplements out
there very very good very healthy
natural and you can check the link in
the description box that is nature's
blend black seed oil and they have other
things as well oh yeah no it's a boy boy
boy
hope you enjoyed the video so would you
so we were talking before the show about
the Trinity what implications do you
think this particular argument has on
the trainee because if we say that well
this thing has to be one I mean and the
Trinity postulates that there is 3 and 1
and 1 or 3 & 3 or 3 independence if you
like well if you like 3 necessary first
persons well the father is necessary
their son is necessary doorless presence
with will there be a contradiction in
your mind with with those two things
yeah so this is a hard question for me
in part because this is something that
I've been kind of thinking about and
there are different models for how this
might work
and I find it helpful to think in terms
of models one thing that I was saying
before the show too is that I think
sometimes people will divide over things
where they actually can have a greater
unity I think about this with respect to
my wife Rachel
so I have a relationship with her
connection with her and I don't have to
like figure out the inner structure to
know her personally I mean I can
speculate about her inner structure and
I can have theories and some theories
will make more sense than others so I
think this argument for oneness helps to
constrain some of the options in terms
of theological interpretation and just
to give kind of one model and there's a
classic kind of traditional articulation
of this of this model where there's a
kind of hierarchy within God so if you
think of God is supreme and so God by
virtue of his supremacy enjoys supreme
attributes including love and doesn't
depend on creation in order to enjoy
that love and so we could imagine then
the supreme love being within the nature
of God somehow
but then how does this fit with oneness
right and so one idea would be that you
can make a distinction even within the
structure of God as like one person
within God is the primary God the Father
and then from the Father proceeds the
son from the father and the son for see
the spirit so there's this kind of
almost hierarchy yeah and and and I know
there's objections to that in in further
clarifications I could be made there but
that would be one model where to be very
honest I don't see any contradiction in
that I don't see that that's of the form
of a and not a so that that would be one
model that one could think about but I
don't think that it's it's essential
really to see God as supreme and as
ultimate and perfect I see what you're
saying so you're so interesting it's
like you're moving away from the kind of
Nicaea no constantinople understanding
of 300 eternal co well they would be Co
eternal so now this is quick my
understanding is this is consistent with
this coequal Co eternal view and that
it's actually part of that tradition
that there is a kind of eternal
progression or eternally what does it
begotten but not made sort of thing like
it's there there is a kind of hierarchy
even within the system but the hierarchy
is the hierarchy does it assume that one
of them has more say power than the
other one no so they would all sort of
share equally in supreme power supreme
knowledge and supreme goodness so in
that sense they would be equal so so
there maybe they wouldn't be equal in
all senses because they wouldn't all be
the same person in that sense but they
would all be equal and sharing the
divine nature I mean another model of
this would be that there there's a sense
in which the whole is prior to the parts
and so there the whole is sort of the
ultimate uncaused undifferentiated and
it's in virtue of the whole that it has
three elements or three members would
you say three would you say three plots
as well yeah yeah you know I used that
term part but I use it in the most
general sense so that it will include
can stitch you
members because then someone may argue
that material parts yeah clothes not
material but still we're moving in the
kind of modeless direction from a
theological tradition yeah so that would
be another model were yet where you
could allow that you know and I
understand some people say that's heresy
right you know but I care about truth
right not what like people say no I
appreciate that and that's why I'm
before in the beginning of this show I
really found interesting that we were
talking about smart phones you said
something really beautiful he said I
don't carry smartphones because I don't
like to you know follow the crowd or you
know yeah and I found that very powerful
but what I was what I was gonna say
because we've only got like 10 minutes
left going on oh you're you're busy is I
think that here's here's the Islamic
kind of objection to the trinny right
obviously we talked about if we go back
to the necessary being right and we
talked about the fact that if you have
more than one necessary being then what
if one could be the other or you put it
in a beautiful way so if something had
the power to be something else then it
would attend show the potential right
then it wouldn't be it wouldn't be
necessary but it would be contingent so
yeah so in the same way if we say that
the father has the potential to exhibit
the characteristics of the Holy Spirit
say that one could argue that this is
problematic from that angle because
there you have three necessary persons
right and that that's what I the other
angle is if we accept yeah and I want to
agree with that yeah I agree with that
that's why this provides a kind of
constraint oh and how that could be
unpacked yeah there have to be some
attributes that are essential they can't
just be potentially the other in that
sense so with if they share a nature
it's essentially shared but then it then
hold if you think about it the sharing
okay this is the chronicler